voilà brio tout cela que j y ai appris à
tout cela la fri
m
satan
b
[Musique]
enfin souffrent quant au shabak ou
compagnon est en fait ben
on y réaliser des biens on a pris la
place et les insultes ou me dis tout le
temps dire que je sers à rien que sans
lui je sais rien tous dotés ça sent fort
mais pèse beaucoup et a récemment fait
base il a commencé à taper faute
d'accord il ya violence conjugale quand
une personne dans le couple va ressentir
va avoir un sentiment qui n'est pas bien
qu'elle n'ait pas écouté qu'elle n'est
pas entendue ou qu'elle va subir des
choses des choses qui peuvent être
caractérisées par la loi de plusieurs
formes
les violences qui peuvent être visités
physique pardon des violences qui
peuvent être verbale des violences qui
peuvent être économiques des violences
qui peuvent être sexuelles ou
psychologiques ou un mélange de tout ça
à shanghai il me fait peur je sais plus
comment faire peur de vivre avec lui
encore peur que les cours d'accord les
femmes qui viennent chez nous viennent à
la rencontre des conseillères conjugales
pour avoir un espace d'écouté libre non
jugeant et qui va être de façon à ce que
ce puisse être orientés après vers les
professionnels ou le professionnel qui
pourrait l'aider à aller un peu plus
loin si elle le souhaite toujours une
personne victime n'a peut-être juste
besoin d'en parler à quelqu'un et ce
n'est peut-être ne se sont pas
suffisamment près tous armés ou équipés
ou sûre d'elle-même pour pouvoir aller
plus loin nous nous en proposons ça
aussi c'est de venir nous voir de venir
déposer avec nous et non la compagnie et
on prend le temps d'accompagner
[Musique]
durand famille je peux pas en parler
personne est au courant de notre famille
proche de ce qui se passe bien
du coup je leur dit non parce que
peut-être qui se marchaient pas si je
sais pas vraiment pour moi je n'arrive
pas à dire parce qu'il commençait à peu
de la faction quoi dites vous que c'est
votre faute
mais parce que c'est moi qui me suis mis
avec qui elle est peut-être mieux
régions du québec
il ya plein de choses qui peuvent faire
qu'une victime va se taire la peur la
honte la culpabilité ça peut être une
dame qui va nous dire que mais je peux
pas dire ça à ma famille ma famille
m'avait prévenue au départ de pommes
d'être et que ce monsieur mais je les
fais quand même parce que je l'aimé
parce qu'il m'aimait je pensais qu'il
mène et d'autres vont vous dire mais
c'est le père mon enfant ou de mes
enfants
d'autres ne vont pas partir ne vont pas
parler tout simplement parce que
financièrement elles ont peur de ne pas
pouvoir être assuré derrière aussi
beaucoup ne vont pas parlé parce
qu'elles nous ont l'impression qu'elles
ne vont pas être cru tout simplement
qu'elles ne seront pas écouté qu'on va
leur dire mais non c'est pas vrai tu
inventes détruites ou tu l'a peut-être
un peu cherché si elles viennent chez
nous c'est justement parce qu'elles
savent qu'ici jamais on va leur dire ça
au contraire on va leur dire je vous
entends madame je vous crois et je suis
là
[Musique]
parce que j ai appris votre avis je
t'aime du tibet comme quelqu un pour
tous tous comme ça et voilà il un
nouveau débat s'est entiché je sais bien
que moi j'aime pas que tu parles avec
des gens et du coup et moi je ne me
sentais pas d'enfant parce que ceux-ci
qui veut pas et si j'ai fait à ma et du
coup même des fois j invite les gens à
la rue mais c'est juste pour vous mais
je dis que l'on vaut changer même si
j'ai dit je fais comme si j'ai pas dis
pas ce que je dis c'est que je suis
d'avoir quelqu'un me dit il ne vous
agresse jamais devant témoins non cette
dame après je l'accompagnent quelle que
soit la décision qu'elle veut prendre je
n'ai pas lui imposer quoi que ce soit
bien sûr que dans l'idéal il faudrait
qu'elle porte plainte il faudrait que il
faudrait que mais le il faudrait que
chaque femme a sa solution chaque femme
à sa vie je ne suis pas experte de leur
vie donc oui je vais les accompagner
oui je les oriente mais c'est à elle de
prendre la décision
si vous allez ont cherché refuge à
l'euro près de votre ami si vous n'avez
déjà un petit et lui ne veut pas
l'entendre
46 des faits rapidement apport à quai
parce que c'est ça qui vous fait perdre
mon temps pour aller mal pour aller vous
avez peur de quoi donc défini par
actuellement qu'est ce qu'il a dit ou ne
pas vous être chemin
[Musique]
le conseil conjugal nous n'apportons pas
de solution on les a bien sûr on les
connaît mais la meilleure solution c'est
celle que la femme choisira elle c'est
celle que elle voudra mettre en place et
prête à mettre en place et nous nous
sommes là pour les accompagner là dedans
tourmag com
[Musique]